the streets of Manhattan are empty from
an essent of the days after 9/11 but
within New York's hospitals doctors say
they're under siege the number of cases
across the country has soared we don't
get control of this quickly like in the
next two to three four weeks our
hospital systems will be overwhelmed
under mounting pressure from state
governors President Trump says his
administration has shipped 8 million
respirator masks
he's also signed an executive order to
prevent the hoarding of critical medical
supplies but if you are sitting on it on
a warehouse with masks surgical masks
you will be hearing a knock on your door
more than 100,000 Americans are under
orders to stay home despite the growing
number of cases Trump says he hopes to
reopen the country soon we are not going
to let it turn into a long-lasting
financial problem started out as a
purely medical problem and it's not
going to go beyond that we're just not
going to allow that to happen
meanwhile Congress remains at a
stalemate over a nearly two trillion
dollar economic rescue package the
Republican plan stalled by Senate
Democrats bill still includes something
that most Americans don't want to see
large corporate bailouts with know
almost no strings attached the
government is also fast tracking
experimental drug treatments one
endorsed by President Trump as a
possible game-changer against the corona
virus has not been approving effective
in a clinical setting and an Arizona man
whose self medicated with the drug to
treat his corona virus has died Heidi
Joe Castro al Jazeera Maryland